now let's see this this guy looks like
he's in the air what is this video
coming in from Tyler from Illinois it's
that new Top Gun he's on a windmill yeah
oh you know all those [ __ ] things on
yeah exactly how can you google it there
it is scary dude whenever I see them I
get nervous I do well with Heights but
they got wind up there dude that's the
scary part - you gotta go all the way up
there guess what's up there wind scary
280 feet 180 feet you could make it if
you came off of that I've done 60 feet
you ever done like you're a jump out of
a cliff your athletic movement up with
your land feature dog Bryn is like you
ever tumble roll out of a glacier good
guys another 60 there's a dude in our
town it was 75 feet he went up on this
bridge was talking all this [ __ ] he's
like watch us you little eggs right and
no offense if anybody might be gay or
their name is [ __ ] that's just what he's
that's what I would never say that we
don't support them yeah he goes watch
this ye little gay people we know and he
jumped off if I can hit a boat that was
did he die like [ __ ] up huh yeah
that's awesome oh yeah that's the same
that's like it can't a real cannonball
cannonball no for reals cannonball wow
man this is awesome so this guy's one of
those wind workers man this guy's doing
God's work up there I don't do well with
hi it's not for me I'd love to get up
there and put on one of those things you
like those little squirrel suits and
just scoot off that thing
yeah take a date out chain maybe you
could take whoa you know what bungee
jumping and Max
let's see who comes back no sky jeepers
alright yeah $7.00 in kanji jumping its
duper one duper 1:02 bungee jumpin in
Mexico they tie a rope to you and you
just run south of the border man that's
why what was this question when okay
bungee jump in Mexico also known as
Mexican rule at its problems you'll
survive is that something you're
interested in chin just jumping out of
anything dude I have a skydiver inside
it some friends of mine that work down
there great guys and it's an amazing
experience it's so easy to just buzz
down there time buzzing no way I ain't
jumping I play in the bro yeah the date
I'm talking babe let's send him on the
date you down to do that chin why not
because you look like you'll be real
scared but you can trust these people
man these people a lot of more former
military let them have served abroad nah
too much living to do man
but have kid that do it but your kids
don't want you to die doing something
what die what around the house [ __ ]
driving to the post office [ __ ] that it
can't be like hey Dad died because he
wanted to make sure chin got his dick
sucked and we do that's what he said go
to be supportive I'm not doing anything
with his wiener dude I'm right either
but that's the end goal here no it is
and I'm oh yeah he's not looking for
anybody could just jerk off near
somebody's face while he's looking for
he's looking for love you he's looking
for a connection hunt Jen yes he's 46
man okay you're right
they just may be just bungee jump in
Mexico dude if he make us through that
chin he's four I get through anything
bro bro he's 46 he's dressed like Willy
Loman on kedo Thank You Russ bro yeah it
looks like [ __ ] look like if I can
George Michaels little sod bees in here
yes brother
I see no one Ike's man honestly I've had
some height instances where when I used
to do the road rules shall we subdue
heights Tom runs really well I'm very
good one time we had a walk between two
hot air balloons on a plank oh and it
was crazy huh for ratings
no from I think $1500 Jesus so Kim a
long way bro yeah that's a good point
man it was crazy charmer and my legs I
couldn't even feel them I was so scared
so I just like I kept moving them from
the hip and just one for I can't I'm
getting sweaty talking about I can't do
it but those Heights camera motor I've
always want to do wing-walking though
which is where you're on a plane wing
and you can walk out there because as
long as you're just on the wing you
don't fly off cuz you're with the plane
no never
not for me I'll start crying if I think
too much when I'm on an airplane
really yeah I hate it dammit so no
Heights for me good for you they'll
forgetting through it yeah but it's
scary Allah sometime I think it's hit or
miss you know
[Music]
became nothing
[Music]